acudir a la escuela en Afganistán una
actividad de alto riesgo para las
menores afanas unas 80 niñas fueron
hospitalizadas durante el fin de semana
con síntomas respiratorios y
neurológicos luego de ser envenenadas en
las aulas de dos colegios de primaria
también varios miembros del personal
educativo presentaron síntomas
fue al comienzo de las clases y las
alumnas que acudieron a ella resultaron
envenenadas vomitaban y tenían asma
vértigo y dolor de cabeza
si bien Es la primera vez que se produce
este tipo de ataques contra las
estudiantes afganas en la última década
desde que el grupo talibán se hizo con
el control del país en agosto de 2021 la
educación de las niñas y adolescentes ha
estado restringida como parte de la
política de gobierno de los talibanes
que entre otras cosas previeron a las
mujeres acudir a las universidades o
cursar la educación secundaria la
agencia de la ONU para la infancia
unicef exigió investigar el incidente
unicef está preocupado por conocer un
supuesto incidente ayer en el que una
sub-80 niñas y mujeres enfermaron en dos
escuelas del distrito de San charc en el
norte de Afganistán deseamos a todos los
afectados una pronta recuperación las
escuelas deben ser refugios de seguridad
donde los niños aprendan libres de miedo
las mujeres deberían poder trabajar Sin
poner en peligro sus vidas
a comienzos de este año las menores
iraníes sufrieron envenenamientos
deliberados similares para impedir que
las niñas acudieran a las escuelas unos
atentados contra los derechos de las
mujeres niñas y adolescentes en la
región que siguen sucediendo con total
impunidad